en france au 30 juin dernier 11600
commune disposait déjà de la fibre
optique 25 millions de foyers pouvez
bénéficier de cette technologie qui
permet d'avoir accès à une connexion de
meilleure qualité chez nous où en
sommes-nous du déploiement un sujet
d'autant plus d'actualité que le
télétravail est en pleine progression et
nécessite donc un minimum de débit ont
fait le point aujourd'hui avec notre
invité du jour jean-philippe martignac
bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc le
directeur de val de loire fibre
expliquez-nous
où en est-on alors du déploiement de la
fibre en indre et loire et en loir et
cher alors surveillez de département
d'indre et loire et le loir et cher
nous allons déployer 320000 prise d'ici
ça représente 180 8000 prises dans le
département d'indre et loire
il trie qu'est-ce qu'ils prisent une
prise c'est après ce qui permet d'amener
la leucine à de la fibre optique dans
chacun des logements administrations
entreprises
c'est la même prise que celle que vous
avez pour votre ligne téléphonique dans
votre salon donc effectivement nous
allons construire ses 120 milles prise
jusqu'en 2023 à date aujourd'hui nous
avons construit 38000 prise c'est un peu
plus de 1000 prise par semaine
on progresse sur le déploiement sera
2000 prise par semaine dans le courant
de l'année 2022 afin de réaliser les 320
milles prise au terme de l'année 2023
demain si j'ai bien compris vous deviez
inauguré le dernier noeud de
raccordement optique en indre et loire
ça veut dire quoi alors un noeud de
raccordement optique c11 des 96 points
de départ du réseau sur les deux
départements
c'est un équipement d'une quinzaine de
mètres carrés dans lequel nous mêmes et
des opérateurs installés l'ensemble des
équipements techniques et électroniques
qui vont permettre le fonctionnement du
réseau
depuis ce noeud de raccordement optique
on va tirer des câbles en tous sur
l'ensemble du projet on va tirer quand
même 27 mille kilomètres de câbles sur
les deux départements
oui voilà alors c'est pas on va pas
tirer 27 mille kilomètres sur un imprimé
depuis ce nouveau raccordement on va
alimenter 3800 foyer entreprises ou
administrations
on va poser également une dizaine
d'armoires dans laquelle depuis laquelle
se raccorderont là aussi à peu près 300
300 350 prise à terme est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement aujourd'hui tous les
habitants d'indre et loire et du loir et
cher d'ici 2023 vont avoir accès à la
fibre ou est ce qu'il reste à les lire
des petites fermes aux avec des impasses
où la fibre n'arrivera jamais non la
fibre à vivre à part tout à faire un
grand parti ni l'obligation à c'est
l'engagement que nous avons pris auprès
des collectivités territoriales qui ont
fait le choix de l'entreprise de vente
de leurs fibres
nous travaillons conjointement avec le
syndicat plus collectivité locale val de
loire numérique et qui nous échangeons
tous les jours qui regroupe les
départements les deux départements la
région ainsi que l'ensemble des
intercommunalités et les engagements que
nous avons pris c'est une couverture à
100 % du territoire y compris la
dernière ferme dans le 2
le plus petit village où le plus petit
un mot effectivement c'est un projet qui
est oui globalement coûteux puisque le
projet global tourne autour de 480
millions nous sommes subventionnés par
les collectivités à hauteur de 52
millions puisque c'est un une délégation
de service public est ce que la demande
des particuliers est aujourd'hui plus
pressante pour se raccorder à la fibre
avec la mise en place du télétravail
alors on a en a senti quelques
évolutions sur les dernières prises que
nous avons pu ouvrir à la
commercialisation
ils font vraiment à peu près un an pour
atteindre 30% de commercialisation on a
vu des pics à l'issue du premier
confinement là aussi on sent bien qu'il
ya une attente sur l'ensemble des des
prix ce que l'on distribue et
effectivement la courbe de
commercialisation est un peu plus rapide
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de la 5g c'est une
technologie qui a peu détracteurs
finalement c'est totalement différent
la singette une technologie indienne
nous nous tirons du câble delà de la
fibre de la fibre qui serpente en vie
qui serpente en sous-sol avec serpente
sur nous utilisons les infrastructures
existantes des poteaux d'électricité ou
de téléphone mais est également en
enterré et donc c'est un câble qui va
remplacer à terme le câble de cuivre qui
vous amène le téléphone chez vous et
bien c'est de la fibre optique cdu verts
ce n'est pas du cucs et du verre merci
merci d'être venu nous expliquer le
déploiement de la fibre
merci beaucoup